こんにちははじめしゃちょーです24時間
断食した後
[音楽]
何するんだっけ
思い出しました24時間
断食した後回転スイーツ脱げにくいてて
皆さんようやく私の適正に気づきました
そう私はじめしゃ社長大の穴塔です今まで
24時間断食何も食べなかった後にわんこ
そばをしたり24時間何も食べなかった後
に一蘭のラーメンの替え玉壁紙さんです
けどもどうもどうも思ったような結果が出
なかったなんなら食えなくなってた気づい
たんですラーメンとかそばとか麺類はもう
無理です俺の範囲外でしたもうそんなのは
普通に適量でいいんですけどもお菓子
甘いものであればもうめちゃくちゃ大好物
で永遠に食べれるので無限に食えるのでは
ないかそしてそれに加えて24時間お腹が
すかすことによってもう爆発的に
必ず
必ず必ずお店のスイッチ全部食べます
はいそもそもその海底スイーツ屋さんて
いうのがなんかすごくないですかなんか
東京にあるんですよそういう回転寿司なら
ぬ回転スイーツっていうスイーツが
どんどん回転するらしくてそんな夢のある
ような場所があっていいのかともう絶対
回転してくれて全部食べれるのでちょっと
今回そちらに挑戦してみたいと思いますと
いうわけで今の時間15時31分あと30
分後に16時になります明日16時に開店
していく予算に行くので今から30分間
程よくお腹膨らませればいいなと思って
ますいただきます
よここでしょうもないの食べると24時間
開けると胃が小さくなるので限界まで
膨らませますでこの状態維持したまま24
時間経ってお腹空腹状態でいけばこの
キャパ分入るとで更に
拡張させることが大事なので早速ちょっと
おいしく最後のご飯
食べていきたいと思いますさっき
マジでいただきます召し上がってください
いやもう好きなもの全部網羅したからね
コーラ飲んじゃうよ早速
[音楽]
いいえ一口まずビッグマックだな
とりあえずいやもうだってさ24時間結構
きついしこの後編集とかもあるからマジで
力つけとかないといただきます
[音楽]
いや全然食べてください
じゃあちょっとたくさん食べてください
もう時間だけちょっと見て4時までです
からタイムリミットあと20分ですうん
結構早食いしないと絶対全部食います絶対
食え
待ってさすがに今日はさすがにねあれ
紙ストローじゃないシェイクだけ
[音楽]
マジで無理なんだけど
わかるぶよぶよになるじゃないですか
ほんまに無理無理もちろん環境を気にし
てるのはわかるけどさ本当に飲みやすさ
だけの話するとさ結構きつくない間違い
です
持ち歩こうかな5分置いたらこれぶよぶ
本当にだったらさこれ持ち歩いた方がいい
よね
やってよ
うんナイス次は
食べちゃうよいっぱい食べてください
いただきます
うまい
ごちそうさまでした
ねハヤシライスを満たしておかないと多分
全然もたないから欲望のままに飛びますね
[音楽]
それ今だから怒られないやつですよそれ
水筒の術子供の頃これしたら殺されてて
マジで怒られてたなんでダメなんだろう誰
かと飲むんだったらめっちゃ嫌だけどさ
スイートの術やんはじめしゃちょーは
スイートの術を推奨しておりますいや推奨
しちゃダメでしょ牛丼もちょっと肉食べ
たいからいただきます
うん
うまいうまい
[音楽]
実はいただきます
うまいこれ10分
ちょっと
全部無理だ今腹何分目ぐらいです
[音楽]
ちょっと悪魔呼びたいと思います悪魔呼び
ますね
ベネズエラが生んだ奇跡の造形美セロハン
テープの悪魔ですセロハンテープの悪魔に
来てもらいましたよろしくお願いします
このセロハンテープの悪魔は何でも食べ
ちゃいますからはい好きなだけ今日は
ありがとうございますじゃあ食わして
いただきますまずはピザ
いやハヤシライス触ったなら食える悪魔
常識
じゃあまずコーラから
飲むんだよ
いただきますあと10分切ってるし悪魔
って俺でも結構苦しいのでもう1人読んで
ます動物
園の
守護神ゴリラの悪魔ですよろしくお願いし
ますいやすごいですよ彼はマントヒヒの
上腕二頭筋を太さによって力を変える悪魔
なので相当強いです何を言ってるかが全く
わからない俺もやめろ
[音楽]
変えてもらっていいですか
あとご飯あとご飯
[音楽]
終了
ちょっと悪魔は帰らせますポン
というわけで今から24時間後に回転
スイーツの店に行ってどれだけ食べれるか
やってみたいと思います結構断食はもう
なんか得意になってきてるんでそんなに
苦しくないと思うんですけどもしっかりと
食べずにやっていきたいと思いますでは
24時間後にやりましょう
[音楽]
渋いかな
夕方あんなに食べたのに深夜とかさ寝る前
って
めっちゃお腹すくんですよねなんかお腹が
キューってなってます
助けてください
おやすみ
[音楽]
おはようございます二度寝して気づいたら
お昼になってましたなんかそんなに超
きつくないんですけど
めっちゃきついですねあと4時間
頑張ります
というわけで原宿に来ております
[音楽]
はいというわけで24時間経過しました
もう無理よ
初めて来たから
めっちゃテンション上がってます
一般的にどれくらい食べられるんですか
平均ちょっと知りたいです
男性が25
[音楽]
じゃあ僕が450行きます早速食べさせて
いただきますいただきます早速見て
くださいこれもううまそう
可愛らしいいただきます
料理だね
[音楽]
可愛い
いただきます
[音楽]
今のところ無限ですよ
うちに入りません
いただきます
ちょっと若干苦味があってめっちゃ
美味しいこれ多分後半役に立ったり
見てくれ
ゼリー
懐かしい用語使うな
え待ってエグいペースいけるんじゃない
これ大丈夫ですね
すごいなあれ今8でしょ
さっき食べちゃったお料理みたいなのあり
ですか一応お店には出てるらしいんですよ
常にありで行きます
かわいいお団子さんです12
[音楽]
クレープが可愛い16
うまっすごい夢の世界だね17
ミカンゼリー
いきました女性平均です
か
[音楽]
ガチでボケでやってるんですか
ウォーターサーバーかと思ってた世界記録
ってどれくらいなんですか
いただきます
もうマジで助かるこれ行きましょうか
212232425
お腹こんだけ空いてないと25分で結構な
気がする
満腹感がすごい
ジョークです
だいぶディープなじゃがいもこれ北海道産
ですか
小籠包
281回メインショーで最後のスイーツで
締めにガットぐらい行きたいと思います
目標は一応
25031を記録は更新していく
ちゃんと制限時間があるらしく時間食べ
られるわけじゃないらしい俺は食べたいん
だけど無理になる可能性もあるそこは理解
しといてほしいです結構早食いの性能も
大事俺はいけるんだけど行ってもらって
いいですか
今やばいここら辺マジでコスト1100
ごめんちょうど今爆発力のあるメンツが目
の前を通ってますね
ここをしっかりスナイプしていく29
やばいもう完全にスイーツの味じゃない今
スイーツの下じゃなくなってる
なんだこれ
ここでご飯はやばいやつ
米食べたくなる瞬間来ると思うんだよ
ん
だ
何ですか
行きましょう
37383940きましたまだまだ行け
ます41445464748
在庫切れ
[音楽]
でもまだ行ってます
けどまだまだ行けますよ555657
[音楽]
まだタイムも来てないもう無理だ限界です
か
24時間
断食してきたところ57
皿食べることができました
[音楽]
比較的すごい方ではある
倍いってます
けどどうしても甘いもの食べ続けるとこう
うってなっちゃうからたまに来る料理が
マジでうまいバランス取れてたなっていう
一応今回の挑戦は回転スイーツということ
で
途中結構食べましたけど行かせてもらった
結果
57歳
が限界でした
めっちゃ美味しいです幸せの幸福度が
やばい皆さんの挑戦お待ちしており